hi i'm currently dying
and i would like to schedule a
consultation
sarah
hi there i'm sure you're familiar with
the process
when you know you're going to die
you can have yourself cloned
you have very clean skin
i like your shirt
[Music]
but life has thrown you a curveball
you're not dying anymore
the duel to the death will be in
approximately one year wait did you say
duel to the death
[Music]
i can't have two of you walking around
forever
be ridiculous
[Music]
do you want to live
yes
i don't believe you
and maybe a size smaller than you
i'm going to kill her
a properly trained human body is a
weapon
you're pretending to be me while i'm
still alive
even if i can't be with her i don't want
to be with you
[Music]
always use the gun if it's an option
i find guns to be boring
and overused
if it's the difference between life and
death it's okay to be boring
your mental tricks aren't going to work
taking over my life was the plan not
stealing it
[Music]
this is my life
she's not going to take it from me
[Music]
what are my chances zero nothing is ever
absolutely certain though this most
certainly is
[Music]
i really value your friendship i'll miss
that when you die
speaking of which any updates
[Music]
[Music]
you